by a vote of 10
to zero caser you are evicted from the
big brother house
caser i don't like that i'm talking to
you right now
what happened why can you not make it to
jury on this show
i just i don't know it's this is not a
format for me apparently
so yeah that's sort of that's i'm never
going to be able to live this down i'm
the guy who never makes it to the jury
that played three times never dirty once
that's me
i'm gonna put that on t-shirt i mean the
fans are
absolutely crushed that you and janelle
are out
so early in this game uh what do you
want to say to the fans who are
disappointed in how this season's going
look i don't want to to sort of
uh displace any blame but you know what
what are we supposed to do like it's a
yeah
we're an iconic pair that was placed in
the house with no cover i mean we had
nowhere to hide
um and all eyes were on us
from day one so naturally
janelle in the in inside the house was
just kind of saying hey listen
we shared this sort of sentiment back
and forth to one another
i'm sorry that you know we're here
together
um had you know we not been together
maybe we would have made it further in
the house my response to her was
i wouldn't have it any other way you
know i'd rather not make it very far
and be able to play with janelle again
well let's talk about this eviction
speech that is going
to go down in big brother history
i just want to say i really love every
one of you guys on a personal level
uh now when it comes to game play and
strategy i think you guys all suck
no one's willing to take a shot when
did you decide that's how you wanted to
go out you know part of
probably uh two days prior part of it
was because
i was trying to do everything in my
power to convince
um members of the house to do something
wake up
get with it this is an extremely sleepy
season as far as i'm concerned
no one was willing to take a big shot or
make a big move
and so you know i come from the the the
sort of the the thought of of that
um if you're gonna do something you've
got to do yourself now i never won hoh
um and so i never had the power to do so
so i figured you know what i'm still in
this game technically
i have this speech why not and at least
i owe it to the fans i felt like the
fans were probably sitting at home
thinking for the love of god please
something
happen in this game if you want to have
a reunion
and sit around and maybe play charades
then keep things the same
if you want to play all-stars and keep
me here
we'll continue to play i hope i have
your bow coating
oh you got it i thought i'd shake things
up and light a fire and make
people feel a little uncomfortable so
that they maybe wake up and decide that
you didn't come to this house to have
taco tuesday with each other the fans
were definitely waiting for that moment
so
thank you for bringing it to us you said
that everybody's gameplay sucks right
now
whose game who's sucking the most casar
who's doing the worst
honestly as far as i'm concerned um
anyone who's not willing to
um make an impactful move
um they all suck i'll say the person who
i thought sucked the most was memphis
and then he surprised me so i will give
him the most credit i thought he was
literally just like laying in bed and
uh trying to make his back feel better
but
um he he did surprise me i think anyone
who
sort of um finds themselves in a sort of
large
alliance where they have a safe haven
and are just
kind of playing the duck and cover
position floating within an alliance
um it's kind of annoying i can
understand
why they would do it but at the same
time i think
the expectation with all-stars is that
you bring a bunch of people
back who are gunners who who are like
ready to shake things up and play an
incredible game
i think you just saw a whole lot of the
same
composition of folks and i think that
was part of the problem like everybody
was like
all right i'm gonna do nothing and be
nice to everyone
and so that caused everyone just to fall
into a deep sleep
and i was like oh my god get me out of
this place and like please
somebody do something it feels like it's
definitely the clash of
old school versus new school and it's
interesting that memphis has fallen into
kind of this new version of playing the
game because
so julie revealed that big six-person
alliance to you that memphis is in but
there are two other large alliances as
well
happening in the house so you have
bailey devon
enzo cody and danny in an alliance
called the slick six and nicole knows
about that one
and then you have cody danny enzo and
nicole in a different alliance called
the core form
does any of that surprise you uh yeah i
mean i didn't i didn't know
about it so um
look i i not entirely surprised only
because
it's not my first time playing so it
would be incredibly
naive to think that there were multiple
alliances taking place
within the house was there anyone in
particular you were hoping to blow up
their game
by the speech or was it just everybody
get it
it was everyone um i didn't single
anybody out i was
i gave cody a hard time uh particularly
because i felt as though maybe he had
uh multiple kind of associations
but that was only also strategic like
there's nothing particularly
um against cody it was just more like
how could i use cody to infuriate more
people
danny went into the dr to cast her vote
and called your speech
disrespectful and tasteless what do you
think of that danny's easily offended
and she needs to get over it honestly
like she um i knew that she was gonna
come off that way because i
i i knew that i figured the only two
people that were going to be most
offended by what i was going to say were
going to be danny and nicole
and i can tell by their body language
they had their arms crossed and they
were like
really offended um but here's what i
have to say about that
um who cares like i was i
i didn't say anything personal about you
or your families or
anything else so i don't know how that's
tasteless
if anything um i wanted people to feel a
little bit of a pinch
on my way out and i thought it was kind
of funny another great moment
from your eviction episode was you're
talking to julie and she says
the house voted you back in and your
face went
flat she was referencing the first time
you played the game but you'd seem like
you didn't want to go back in that house
i mean you have to understand like
it's a myriad of emotions right like
it's bittersweet like
part of it's like i get to go home see
my family and it's all like
part of like staying sane throughout
this process is managing expectations
so if you've already felt like you've
walked through those doors
and you've kind of moved on to the next
thing
in your mind to think that you're like
going to go back into that house
obviously i'm extremely grateful to be
part of this process
i wouldn't have it any other way but
it's just like you feel as though you're
just getting rocked back and forth i
i was like shocked i'm like oh my god
holy crap am i really gonna go back in
this house again
so i i just i was like i just sent me
home at this point
i don't know if i want to go back again
so are you
done three times you're out i said
the last time i was on the show i said
i'm never doing this again
um and here i am 15 years 15 years later
so
either i'm you know glutton for
punishment i uh
you know who knows maybe if there's like
more
you know social disorder and and chaos
in this world
that's the thing that's going to bring
me back again i have no idea but
um i think i like all of this i i do
enjoy
being able to use this
um medium as a way to
to speak to folks and to be and to to
have a message
so you know i don't know how that's
gonna look
uh for me but this is it's a good thing
and it works
so i can't tell you yeah you told julie
you came back more so for the platform
than for the win do you feel like it was
mission accomplished
absolutely i feel like i was able to say
what i needed to say
and i think some people along the way
sometimes say well i'm not here for the
money
maybe with this show or other shows
i truly did not come back for the money
and i hope i hope people understand that
to wrap things up here christmas is now
hoh
what do you hope she does with this
christmas
oh wow uh jeez
i think things are gonna get a little
wild
um what do i hope she's gonna do
as a fan of the show i hope she pulls a
big move i'm afraid she might be going
after she either she's probably going to
go after the other alliance
i think dave vaughn and bailey might be
going up all right well
again i am sad to see you out of the
house but i'm sure you're happy to go
home
see your kid get back to life it's
bittersweet
believe me i'm i'm i'm sad to be out as
well but you know
i i try to make the most of it you gotta
you gotta go
check up on allah janelle's tweets she
has a lot of thoughts about the season
a lot of thoughts about nicolette she
does not like
he's still at it huh oh geez oh man i
told her i was like you know you gotta
tone it down a bit
but you know what that's what people
love about janelle and she
is certainly not toned down even at this
point in her life so
why people are sad to see both of you go
but here we are